we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine to david p let's take a
listen to this voicemail that came in
from our buddy Troy York yes they're
back man I was listening to james howard
counselors podcast and he had the
chemist professor David Cola money so
and they were talking about the left and
how liberals and today's youth
protesters uh are basically little
Maoists and in their actions and
attitude and they actually remind me of
the followers of uh Pol Pot in Cambodia
and I think you ought to get over it
Donald Trump is the president and you
need to have psychological help to find
out your own inside issues and problems
in your hatred for Donald Trump I think
that you are jealous in your green
jealous or perhaps uh uh upset that
you're sexually aroused by Donald Trump
right and this is why you always talk
about him every day I think Troy York
hit it right on the head guys I'm upset
with myself because I'm just so sexually
attracted to Donald Trump that I just
can't bear that now he's going to be
president for four years that mean how
could you not be with that hair yeah
right yeah uh okay well Troy you're
continuing to enlighten and inform the
david pakman show audience on the bonus
show today us life expectancy declines
we will talk about that the weather
channel has a message for Breitbart and
a spice company has denounced the Trump
brand of hate and sales soared seemingly
a good business decision david
pakman.com slash membership to sign up
david pakman.com slash donate check out
the indy gogo fundraiser that is in day
two as of today